la pequeña localidad de bailén en el
este de alemania ostenta un doble récord
registró la incidencia de casos de kobe
19 más elevada del país en diciembre de
2020 y es la circunscripción donde el
partido de extrema derecha obtuvo más
votos en las últimas elecciones sophie
facto continúa en realmente hacen muy
buen trabajo es un bastión de los
escépticos del cobi 19 no conozco a
nadie que se haya muerto de covite en
cambio si a gente que por culpa de la
vacuna se enfermó mucho o que murió
suerte que está a efe de al menos si
ellos nos escuchan nosotros nos
consideran fascistas
el diputado de a efe de carsten hill se
fue el más votado en la zona en 2017 y
tiene muchas posibilidades de conservar
su escaño sin vacilar pone en duda la
gravedad de la pandemia
creemos que las cifras de la incidencia
están manipuladas para atemorizar a la
población es insoportable ver lo que se
llega a hacer para aterrorizar a la
gente
tras haber centrado su identidad en el
rechazo a la inmigración el partido de
extrema derecha a efe se presenta ahora
como brazo parlamentario de los anti
mascarillas y anti vacunas la campaña
del partido se basa en lo que llaman una
alemania normal
quiero que nuestro país vuelva a ser
normal es la palabra que resume todo a
lo que aspiramos normal
algunos miembros de aede se manifiestan
regularmente al lado de los anti
mascarillas movimiento con integrantes
bajo vigilancia por las unidades de
información policial en bausen se
encuentran todos los domingos en una
carretera departamental a pesar de que
aquí el kobe 19 haya causado cerca de un
millar de víctimas mortales klaus kröll
es director administrativo de una
parroquia y consejero municipal para él
la relación causa-efecto es evidente
un partido que niega la realidad de la
pandemia y que fomenta el rechazo a la
vacunación considero que es muy
peligroso
peligroso entre otros para sus propios
votantes la mitad de ellos rechazan la
vacunación